le sport maintenant c'est désormais la
meilleure équipe de foot masculine
d'Indre-et-Loire depuis sa superbe
performance en championnat cette année
devant son tour dans le classement là où
CC monte en National 2 le club d'avoine
n'avait jamais atteint ce niveau alors
c'est une totale nouveauté une nouvelle
division qui implique des changements
sportifs mais aussi matériel pour
adapter le terrain explication de
Romainville
derrière on passera que sur du jeu
d'accord
deux équipes avec moi un petit peu
différent de ce qu'on a fait hier mais
dans le même esprit une équipe qui
travaillera jeu à trois sur le but
promis on national 2 la voie olympique
Chinon ciné va découvrir pour la
première fois de son histoire le
quatrième échelon national après la
Ligue 1 la Ligue 2 et le National donc
armorimbaud le coach veut que son groupe
garde l’état d'esprit combatif de la
saison dernière celui qui l'a fait
briller en championnat et en Coupe de
France le truc moi c'est surtout ne pas
ne pas se rabaisser croquer dedans voilà
il faut qu'on fasse la saison qu'on a
envie de faire après une saison il y a
plein de il y a plein d'éléments qu'on
maîtrise pas les blessures et tout ça
donc on peut pas encore savoir
exactement comment ça va se passer mais
ce que je veux c'est que d'entrée de jeu
on envoie on garde nos principes et les
principes qui ont mené le groupe en
National 2 c'est le courage et c'est la
rigueur défensive nombreux ont été les
matchs gagnés d'un but nombreuses ont
été les victoires acquises en fin de
match là veut surprendre son monde sans
prétention mais sans complexe non plus
si on attaque un championnat en disant
que on va descendre où on va le perdre
rapidement autant pas jouer je pense que
c'est important de se fixer de se fixer
des objectifs à la hauteur je pense
qu'on a le groupe pour ce maintenir on
n'a pas peur des autres équipes on
jouera notre football avec l'envie comme
l'année dernière et puis on verra
comment ça va se passer mais j'ai pas de
j'ai pas d'inquiétude autre changement
avec cette montée cette fois pour les
dirigeants un cahier des charges plus
exigeant de la part de la Fédération
exemple il va falloir rallonger les
bandes touches le tunnel qui mène au
terrain ou encore décaler la main
courante à certains endroits du Stade
Marcel Vignaud on nous demande beaucoup
de choses je me demande si des fois les
personnes qui nous demandent de faire
tous ces travaux vont voir dans les dans
les autres stades parce que quand je
vois le stade Marcel Vignaud je me dis
on est loin d'instaï de Ligue 1 l'enfant
on est comme on n'est pas on n'est pas
ridicule il faut quand même savoir qu'on
a organisé deux fois les championnat s
d'Europe ici donc si l'UEFA a décidé de
nous accorder c'est qu'il voyait qu'il y
avait des infrastructures quand même qui
était capable de le faire sur le terrain
comme dans les bureaux là OCC mise sur
l'engouement créé la saison dernière
même si tout le monde doit garder en
tête qu'il va falloir s'habituer à ne
plus jouer les premiers rôles